yeah all right yeah all right yeah I
feel tough and those they had some right
off the top yeah we uh yeah new york new
york new york that's what we are
yeah everywhere yeah you got to
yeah you got to keep your hands in your
pocket in New York yes y'all y'all are
busy around here man a lot of a lot of
walking like a walk-in and I I like it
cuz y'all got a lot of good crosswalks
the countdown crosswalks yeah I like
those things right there let me know how
long I got to get across the street yeah
cuz I I wouldn't raised on the on the
countdown I just had the man in the hand
and uh yeah cuz you don't you don't know
when the man that a hand gonna come up
you just out there taking a chance with
the man and a hand like man that hand
came up fast as hell right there let me
let me get on at the street but yeah you
see the countdown let you know like I
look up sometime like man that got 34 mo
seconds you know I can I can walk back
and forth then 34 seconds why are you
still in the street cuz I got time
that's why I Street yeah man but it's a
beautiful diversity man that's what we
got a have a diversity I like it cuz its
diversity I don't don't let the noise
get to us don't know yeah I don't don't
don't don't don't build a wall build a
bridge to somebody
yes let's bring the people in man yeah
cuz I know we under new management as a
that's like okay are we under new
management like your favorite restaurant
and you went to like man then people
don't own this stone no moat so yeah
that's what we did a will you know is
like this this don't taste like it used
to when other people have it this way
that's all it is it's a different flavor
that's all it is cuz you know it's
different seasoning that's all that's
going on with with the whole chump
movement it's just different seasoning I
knew he was going wrong cuz it's all
about seasoning what you put in your
food and uh like in the cabinet I was
watching the cabinet selection he
started off wrong with the seasoning
because if I come to your house and look
at your cabinet that let me know you
know how you gonna put what kind of
flavor you put [ __ ] and your greens I
need to know and I was watching this
election as a man that's a that's a lot
of salt right there
[Applause]
[Music]
okay you can't make no-good greens with
all that salt right there we gonna have
high blood pressure right that people
say oh what about being Carson s that's
a different season I say no that's exit
right there that's exact same s that's
not black pepper that's sister to take
your time and take your time you know I
said go you know go you know be around
other people go to different places
sometime where you may not go don't just
stay in your neighborhood go see what
other people are doing like I go to city
sometime I just pop up in places like I
like to go through the morrow sometimes
just to see what people are doing at the
mall what they you know selling that day
little kiosks and that's a new word
right there kiosks you know and yeah
nobody was raised on the word kiosks
that just came out of nowhere right
there
yeah but I didn't call them keyattr I
used to call them little stands that's
what I thought they were like you know
people people say well you get that from
that little stand over there that's
where I thought that you know I've never
said that the kiosks over there
I'm a big fan of the food court at the
mall
cuz I like our samples I lover yeah
shockwave you got someone on a toothpick
I need to know what the hell come on
that to pick it up I love it the ancient
people I love the Asian cuz y'all always
have a sample in this sphere and it's
always a shiny piece of meat it's always
just so shiny man yes I would like a
piece of that shine I mean who don't I
can't turn down no shiny meat and I
understand what it what a sample heals
that's just you know that's you know
that's just a suggestive cells they're
saying if you you like this or shine at
me there's more shining me to purchase
know you know sometime I get to taste in
my mouth I say man I think I want some
more a shining meat you know and they're
so nice I go over and ordered from the
counter she said sir would you like rice
or chow mein and uh I always go with the
rice cuz I still really don't know what
cha man yeah I don't know who to chatter
man I don't know
yeah I went raised on that kind of
spaghetti yes I don't don't put them
peas in I don't want them pain yeah I
don't I don't really baby carrots yeah
but beautiful beautiful people yeah and
they look you know so you just gotta get
to know people every once in a while
they I get the rice and uh they're so
nice with the rice yeah they just just
kept giving me rice just giving me rice
and I said ma'am I just want some rice
but today you know coz yes I don't have
that much shining meatball this rice
right here so that's yeah and I had a
lot of yeah I had like a 60 pound bag of
rice so I gotta found in the small
village to drop this right side I've
been right man man I appreciate the love
and it
thank you
you